[Musique]
[Safia] Moi j'ai rien compris.
[Safia] J'ai adoré
[Fabien] C'est vrai ?
[S] Ah, je trouve ça fou !
Maintenant je vais y réfléchir
mais je comprendrai jamais.
[F] Salut. Aujourd'hui je suis avec Safia
[S] Donc je m'appelle Safia, j'ai une chaîne
qui s'appelle Safia Vendome
Ça fait maintenant 5 ans
que je suis sur YouTube
Ce que je fais c'est surtout
des vlogs, mais
tu sais ce genre de vlogs où tu peux
passer des infos un peu sympas.
J'habite à Barcelone
[F] Eh oui, tout de suite, d'un coup...
du vlog à Barcelone c'est pas
pareil que du vlog à Paris.
Je me suis dis ça fait très longtemps que
je n'ai pas mentalisé quelqu'un sur la chaîne.
Et vous me l'avez souvent dit dans les commentaires.
Donc aujourd'hui : Oui !!
D'abord te faire choisir, pour le coup,
au hasard, un concept.
Alors... J'ai écrit pleins de concepts ici.
[S] Oui
[F] En même temps que je vous parle, vous devez voir
la vidéo de quand j'ai réalisé ce petit carnet.
Et c'est que des concepts avec un symbole. Tu vois ?
Par exemple la Terre avec ... La Terre
[F] Très original...
[S] Ouais...
[F] Un objectif. L'objectif avec la cible.
Je vous en fait passer comme ça vous voyez ça.
[S] Quelle belle fleur !
[F] La nature.
Si vous voulez voir ma qualité
de dessinateur...
J'ouvre une chaîne secondaire.
' Fabien ne sait pas dessiner '
[Rires]
Tu lèves. Tu refermes. Ça marche ?
[S] Ok
[F] Je ne regarde pas
[F] C'est bon ?     [S] Oui
[F] Ok. Maintenant on est partis.
[S] D'accord.         On va où ?
[F] On part d'ici
[F] Tu as le concept et le symbole en tête ?
[S] Ah oui !
[F] Formidable.
Le but c'est de voir ce que l'on peut faire
par rapport au symbole qu'elle a choisi.
Et ce que je pressens
qu'elle a choisi aussi ou pas.
Bon elle arrive.
En tout cas, on est arrivés dans le 20ème.
Devant un resto que j'aime bien,
qui s'appelle  "Les ours"
[S] Aux ours !
[F] Put**n la meuf comment elle me parle.
[Rires]
Qui s'appelle "Les ours",
et euh...
il y a beaucoup de réals,
de cinéastes qui viennent ici
S] Ok.
[F] faire leurs fins de tournages.
[F] On va la poser à la CaseyNeistat
[Éclat de rire de Safia]
[S] Ta présence, ta présence.
Ouais ouais.
[F] Casey, il fait toujours ça tu sais ?
[S] Mais tu sais que je l'ai fait en arrivant ?!
[F] Alors!
[S] Mais arrête ! J'ai fait le même !
[F] Alors tu vas avoir 7 décisions
à prendre sur ce parcours.
7 décisions à prendre,
tout le long de ce trajet.
[S] Ok
[F] On va marcher. A chaque intersection,
tu devras prendre une décision.
Ça marche?
[S] Ok
[F] Je t'expliquerai comment on fera.
La décision c'est pas toi réellement
qui va la prendre ;
c'est aussi le hasard.
[S] D'accord
[F] J'ai pris... au départ ce qui symbolisait
le plus le hasard ; à savoir des dés.
Et je me suis dit on va pas jouer aux dés dans la rue [Rires] c'est très compliqué
du coup j'ai pris un jeu de cartes.
C'était moins compliqué.
Alors là on a une intersection.
[S] Faut que je choisisse la direction ?
[F] Oui, mais on le faire au hasard.
On va utiliser la même procédure à chaque fois.
Donc là il y aura soit tout droit,
soit à gauche, soit à droite.
[S] Mais il est où ton jeu de cartes?
[F] Dans ma poche
[S] A quoi il te sert dans ta poche ?
[F] Un rien la bleuffe tu sais...
" Anh mais il est où ? "
" Dans ma poche. "
" Incroyable ! "
[Éclats de rire]
[S] C'était donc ça !
[F] Je n'aurais jamais pensé à ça !
Mais on peut s'arrêter là.
Ok, on est au top
[S] 1er choix
[F] 1er choix. Alors regarde
ce qui va se passer.
Tu vas prendre le jeu
que tu vas mélanger.
Si je l'ai pris...
Oui.
Mais d'où sort il son jeu ?
Mais ! De la poche !
Alors il n'est pas complet,
tu m'en veux pas. Tu le mélanges.
[S] C'est pas grave s'il n'est pas complet ?
[F] Non, non non.
[S] C'est pas de la triche ?
[F] Non. On s'en fiche.
En fait, j'ai cherché comment
on pouvait avoir...
Parce qu'on aura 3 possibilités au maximum.
On ne reviendra jamais sur nos pas.
[S] D'accord
[F] Et donc j'ai trouvé.
[F] Et à chaque fois ça sera la même chose.
Je ne te le dis pas avant
pour ne pas t'influencer.
[S] Ouais. Bon.
Ok, j'ai mélangé
[F] Tu as mélangé ?
Super. Ok.
Tu mets le doigt sur une carte.
Celle que tu veux toi.
[F] Celle-ci ?
[S] Hmm
[F] Tu la sors du jeu.
Tu ne la regardes pas pour l'instant.
Tu la plaques contre toi.
Si la carte est rouge, c'est à gauche.
En fait c'est dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre dans ma tête.
Si c'est rouge, c'est à gauche.
Si c'est noir, c'est tout droit.
Si c'est valet, dame ou roi,
c'est à droite.
Donc rouge à gauche.
Noir, tout droit.
Figures, à droite.
Et tu as quoi comme carte ?
[S] Une figure, une dame.
[F] Une figure, une dame.
Donc on va...
[S] Là.
[F] à droite.
[F] Exactement. Et ce sera
à chaque fois le même processus.
[S] Rouge, noire, figure.
[F] Exactement.
Donc, 1ère intersection. Nous partons
maintenant sur notre droite.
En fait je voulais fermer les routes pour toi...
[S] Mais la mairie ne t'as pas autorisé c'est ça?
[F] Donc là tout droit on peut y aller aussi ? Ouais.
[S] Ouais.
[F] Tout droit, à droite ou à gauche.
Où est ce qu'on va faire le petit tirage au sort ?
[S] Sur la voiture.
[F - Riant] Sur la voiture... Celle qui va partir,
ce serait tellement drôle.
Ça ferait un super plan !
[Rires de Safia]
[S] Rouge
[F] Rouge, alors... gauche
[S] Gauche
[F] Rouge/gauche, Noir/tout droit et figures/droite
[S] Ah oui parce qu'en plus de pas savoir faire des choix,
j'ai une mémoire de poisson rouge...
[F] Je suis là pour toi.
Tu te souviens qu'à la base,
je t'avais fait 2 propositions :
soit une vidéo où je te mentalise,
[S] Ouais
[F] Comme ça faisait longtemps que je n'en
avais pas fait ça me bottait bien...
Soit un truc... genre sur la mémoire et tout...
Et c'est toi qui a dit "Oh j'aimerais bien que tu
me mentalises ! Sur le thème des choix. J'aime bien."
[S] Et oui, j'aime bien.
[S] Moi j'aime bien comprendre.
[F] Ah oui
[S] Mais moi c'est un truc qui me...
[S] Tu vois ? Je sais qu'il y a
toujours une explication rationnelle...
Mais j'aime bien comprendre. J'aime bien être
bluffée et ensuite chercher à comprendre.
[F] Je ne sais pas si je ferai
une explication de cette vidéo
Je sais pas. Dites nous dans les commentaires
si vraiment vous voulez des pistes,
mais moi à la base je pensais faire cette vidéo,
un peu comme on faisait l'année dernière
c'est à dire, de temps en temps...
Ben, je ne vous dis pas.
Et vous avez vos propres théories
et c'est rigolo.
Ça me fait rire d'ailleurs de les lire
[S] Tu veux que je les porte ?
[F] Ah ben oui. Oui on va le faire
comme ce coup-ci...
[S] C'est moi le trépied
[F] C'est toi le trépied
[S] Jusqu'à ce que j'en puisse plus et que les 400
et quelques mille abonnés soient trop lourds !
[F] Si ça se trouve on en a pris un
entre temps, tu vois ?
[F]Clac !
[S] Ah mais c'est ça. C'est ça !!!
[S] Comment ça marche quand
il y en a un, deux, trois, quatre ?
[F] Et oui... ben, je sais pas...
[F] Bon alors gauche là bas,
tout droit et à droite.
[S] Vous avez compris.
[S] Rouge !
[F] Rouge... gauche !
[F] Donc du coup...        Là bas.
[S] Par là !
On pourrait faire visiter Paris en même temps.
[S] Rouge.
[F] Gauche.
[S] Très bien !
On revient sur nos pas !
[F] Ah ! Je ne pensais pas
du tout qu'on serait là.
[F] Par contre...
[S] J'espère que ce n'est pas
une chasse au trésor alors...
Parce que sinon, on ne risque pas
de le trouver !
[F] Statistiquement... ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'on a rouge d'affilé...
[S] Ah, c'est ça !
[F] Ce qui n'est pas très logique,
en terme de stats.
[S] Ouais.
Et heu... on va pas s'mentir... ça me fait
un peu chier c't'histoire ! [Rires]
[F] Pas figure ?                  Tout droit.
[S ] Gauche !
[S] Tout droit... [Rires]
[F] Rouge à gauche, noir tout droit...
[S]  Dory c'est moi quoi...
[F] Je vais me marrer moi au montage.
[S] Et il m'a quand même refilé la caméra !
[S] Rouge !
[F] Rouge,
[Simultanément]
[F] à gauche                [S] Tout droit !
[F] Non, rouge, noire, figure !
[Rires]
[S] J'ai tellement honte d'avoir
une mémoire pareille !
[F] Rouge, noir ou figure ?
[S] Non, figure.
[F] Figure !? Droite
[S] Ça te va ?
[F] Eh ben c'est super !
[S] C'est super !
[S] Tiens ! J'ai très mal au bras.
[Rires]
[F] Je crois que Safia en a marre.
[S] Non pas du tout !
J'ai juste mal au bras
et après je vais avoir un bras disproportionné
par rapport à l'autre...
[F] Bienvenue sur la vidéo de FabienInShape.
[Éclat de rire de Sofia]
[F] Aujourd'hui, on fait du cardio.
[F - imitant TiboInShape]
"Damn les gens !"
"C'est un plaisir aujourd'hui
de vous retrouver en plein travaux"
de la...la rue Orfila c'était...
j'ai cru voir
Et alors si ne je dis pas de bêtises,
ce hasard sélectif va nous faire
arriver à notre point de départ.
C'est à dire au bar et au restaurant des Ours
[F] Les Ours
[S] Mais... on dirait vraiment !
[Safia se racle la gorge]
[F] De quoi ?
[F] Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
[S] C'était ça le but !?
[F] De revenir sur nos pas ?
[S] Ouais ?
[F] Je sais pas mais est-ce que
cette vidéo a vraiment un but ?
[Rires]
[F] Du coup je la repose là.
[S] D'accord.
[F] Et on est bien.
[S] On est revenu là.
[F] Tu sais j'avais lancé tout à l'heure, euh...
sur mon téléphone, une application...
[S] Ouais
[F] Je vais l'arrêter tout de suite.
[F] Hop ! Heu...
[F] Est-ce qu'on peut l'arrêter ?
Oui on peut l'arrêter.
[F] Voulez-vous vraiment quitter ? Oui !
[F] OK.
[S] Pourquoi t'as ton téléphone à l'envers ?
[F] Ah ? Voilà.
[S] Ah, je croyais que c'était encore un piège.
[S] J'essaye de tout comprendre, même
ce qu'il n'y a pas à comprendre.
[Sirène de police assourdissante]
En fait, y a un truc qui s'appelle,
dans la vie, la synchronicité.
[S] Ouais...
[F] La synchronicité, c'est le hasard remarquable.
[F]C'est à dire...
[ Le véhicule de police passe
juste à côté, sirène hurlante ]
[F] C'est à dire tourner quand les flics passent...
[S] Par exemple.
[F] C'est à dire que... que tu...
tu penses à quelqu'un, ton téléphone sonne :
c'est cette personne-là.
[F] Tu vois ?
[S] Ouais.
[F] C'est un hasard remarquable.
[F] Ou tous les jours tu regardes ton
téléphone à la même heure.
[S] Ouais.
[F] Il est genre 12h12.
Et ça te rend un peu fou, tu vois ?
[F]Et je me suis dit, si on...
sin on s'attache à des concepts,
il y a peut-être des synchronicités
possibles derrières ces concepts là.
Et heu...
Et moi je... je crois que tu ne
l'as pas fait voir à la caméra ton mot ?
[S]Non.
[F] Y a que toi qui le connais
pour l'instant, d'accord.
[S] Ouais.
[F] Moi j'ai une théorie sur ce mot.
[F] Je pense que ce mot,
tu me dis si j'ai bon ou pas,
il représente une espèce de boucle
à un moment donné.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas ?
[S - "énervée"] Ouais.
[F]Je pense que c'est un concept...
dont on ne verra jamais la fin.
[S]Ah lolilol quoi !
[Éclatant de rire] ouais.
[F] Je pense donc que c'est l'infini.
[S] Oui ! C'est ça.
[F] Et c'est drôle parce qu'on a fait,
justement, un circuit infini.
[S] Eh oui !
[F] Et l'application que j'ai lancée, Safia,
c'est une application en fait qui prend nos pas.
[S] D'accord.
[F] Tu sais ?  Une application de course en fait,
le truc de joggeur, classique.
Et... c'est pas si clair que ça,
mais je trouve quand même que notre trajet
ressemble au 8 du symbole de l'infini.
En très gros, il aurait pu être plus court,
mais je vous le fait voir quand même.
[S] Ouais. Mais nous on aime bien marcher.
[F] Et ça c'est le symbole qui était
en face de l'infini. Tu confirmes ça ?
[S] Complètement !
[F] Alors c'est mon symbole de l'infini.
Ça veut dire qu'il y a une grosse synchronicité
entre ce choix que tu as fait toi toute seule,
les décisions qui ont été prises au fur et à mesure,
même quand certaines
m'ont pas arrangé du coup au final,
[S] Ouais.
[F]et qu'on se retrouve ici.
[S]P*tain, merde !
[F] Et ça aurait pu être, du coup,
un autre symbole.
Donc en fait, mon vrai travail,
ma vraie difficulté,
c'était d'avoir anticipé les trajets,
de..., d'après moi savoir ce que t'allais avoir,
pour après faire en sorte d'essayer de manipuler
un peu le hasard ou les chances, les stats
pour qu'on fasse un dessin rapprochant.
[S] Ouais mais d'accord mais...
comment... comment quoi ??!
J'aurais très bien pu prendre l'équilibre !
Qui n'a rien à voir.
[F] Moi je pense que je vais vous laisser là-dessus,
mariner un p'tit moment en fait...
Peut-être qu'on en parlera dans une autre vidéo
où on parlera des... chemins de pensée
qui font qu'on prend une décision ou pas
et je reparlerai de cette vidéo à ce moment-là,
mais je vais pas vous donner de clé pour le moment.
Je trouve ça plus drôle comme ça.
Mais après vous pouvez avoir une autre vision peut-être de point de vue sur la chaîne de Safia,
quand tu raconteras peut-être l'expérience, ou ...
[S] Ouais.
[F] t'as pris quelques images.
De toute manière, allez voir la chaîne de Safia.
Ça me paraît évident.
T'as quoi ? T'as un peu moins de 400.000 abonnés,
je trouve ça scandaleux.
Je pense que quand vous allez découvrir son travail,
ça va passer les 400.000 largement !
[F] En tout cas je compte sur vous ça serait cool !
[S] On verra.
Je viendrai lire les commentaires
que vous lui laissez de toute manière.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo,
Comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de liker
et de vous abonner
et à très bientôt. Ciao !
[S] Salut !
[Musique]